Troy, you wanted to share your Oscar nomination
with the deaf community.
And in all my reading and research,
thought you were so incredibly ingratiating
and sharing of this extraordinary moment in your life
to just open it up to everyone else.
And we have several people in our audience
including students from the New York School for the Deaf.
And we have one gentleman here, Manuel,
would you like to share your story with Troy and Marlee?
(audience applauding)
He's asking me, "I stand?"
"Hi, I'm not sure if you remember me,
but I remember you when you came
to Fanwood, New York School for the Deaf.
And Marlee, I remember you've come to the school
quite some time, and I'm so excited
that you'll get the nomination and the award next month.
We're definitely excited in the deaf community.
You inspired us all, and because of you in that movie,
we want more.
Thank you and I love you so much."
(audience applauding)
"I love the New York School for the Deaf.
It's called 'Fanwood,' and we love Fanwood."
Thank you so much Manuel for your beautiful words.
And may I ask you guys as a last question,
did you know while you were making this film
that it would literally make history?
Yes.
(audience applauding)
"Yes, and 10,000%."
"10,000%."
"And it's historic too."
"While we were shooting the film, I told Troy,
I said, 'This is good stuff.'
I'm gonna be on my best behavior with my language here.
I could have said something else, but anyway.
No, I knew that this is something
that would be an eye opener for everyone,
for the majority of people out there watching this film,
they would be amazed from it.
And yeah, I knew it."
"And my wife, who's a teacher of ASL,
she teaches ASL classes, and her students had a little bit
of an attitude and weren't coming to class
and weren't doing their homework or weren't studying.
And then they found out that her husband was nominated
for an Oscar and all these kids changed their behavior,
suddenly respected my wife and started studying
and doing their homework."
(audience applauding)
Yeah.
"It made my wife's life
so much easier as a teacher, how cool.
Thank you, CODA."
I cannot thank you enough.
I have been waiting and anticipating this conversation
and it truly is one of my favorite films
and it is one of my daughter and I's favorite films now.
So thank you for putting this out into the world.
I feel like from the scene also when she's singing
that I need to read people's faces more.
And the way we realize a pivotal moment of someone's life
is to see and recognize the joy that our children
are bringing to people and how to help foster that.
And it was a very awakening lesson for me.
"Emilia Jones who played that role
of our daughter is just,
I don't know if there's a right word,
but she's the gem of all gems.
And she's such a talented actress,
someone who played so many...
She had so many hats during the making of this film,
and Daniel Durant who played Leo in the film, our son.
The four of us together just melded as actors.
We trusted each other and had a lot of fun.
It was hard work, but at the end, we were very grateful
and grateful to be sitting here and sharing this story
with you and everybody about our wonderful journey."
I'm so excited. I celebrate you.
Marlee, I love you.
Troy, I'm so happy to finally make your acquaintance
and I will happily beg
for more conversations with you anytime.
(Drew chuckling)
"Definitely."
Oh my goodness, everybody.
Thank you, Marlee, Troy.
Thank you Jack and Justin so much.
Jack, I've known you, again, as long as I've known Marlee,
and I'm so happy to make your acquaintance, Justin.
CODA is available to stream now on Apple TV+.
And be sure to watch the 94th Academy Awards this Sunday,
March 27th, on ABC, I will be cheering you on.
(upbeat music)